as many of you know may is mental health
awareness month and this morning we are
hearing from april simpkins she's the
mother of former usa and extra
correspondent chesley chris
chesley died by suicide in january she
was 30 years old her family says that
she had suffered from severe depression
for years and please note we have to
tell you ahead of time the subject
matter of this conversation may be
difficult for some viewers but we're
very glad that april simpkins is here
this morning please know how glad we are
to see you thank you and to have this
this conversation you know to those of
us who knew and loved chesley
you know i i see her as so vibrant that
that lion mane of hair she was so
confident and so beautiful and i think
for so many of us it was such a shock
and a surprise but i like the point that
we need to make today that people don't
understand that depression comes in many
forms there isn't a one size fits all
and i think many people think april
you're in the fetal position you're
walking around in your sweatpants you
look a mess you sound a mess and that is
not always the case that's very true um
even in the case with chesley she was
bubbly and lively and when she came in
through the front door it felt like an
announcement yes um all of my other
children would come through the front
door very quietly and hit the kitchen
and might say hello but she would throw
that door open and say hi mom
depression doesn't always look
like someone is sad or burdened
it is something that for chesley she
learned to live with we're so glad
you're here because it's an important
conversation and because we know you're
still going through a grieving process
here could you talk a little bit about
what that process has been like
difficult yeah um i've never lost
someone so close to me so i don't know
what grief should look like
um chelsea told me you were her best
friend it's not just a daughter that's
correct you were her best friend that's
correct and
there are moments when grief hits me
very hard
and
many times it's in the morning because
that was how we started our day talking
together
um face timing and one of the things
chesley and i talked about after her
first attempt
was starting every day off uh with
gratitude when was her first attempt she
was 30 when she was it was many years
ago she was in her 20s um
and so when we would start our calls in
the morning it was gratitude and what we
were looking forward to that day and
that for her was very helpful
and
so now in the mornings to not have that
makes the mornings very hard even for me
the shower became my best friend yeah
it's where i can grieve the best the
warm water feels comforting um i've
stood in my shower and weeped and cried
and screamed and dropped to the floor
but april had you been worried about her
you said that she there had been an
attempt in her 20s from now she was 30.
yeah most of course we didn't know that
you of course did had you been worried
about her
you know i lived in two worlds i loved
her dearly and deeply
but the other world was knowing that she
was struggling with depression
and
she and i had very intimate
conversations about what she needs from
me for support and she did have a
support group yes um and so
i gave her what she needed from me and
chesley took from everyone what she
needed from them
a hug a smile a kind word she got what
she
needed and so while it didn't plague me
it was always there in my mind
i knew to do the things that she
required of me
as someone who was part of her support
but also her mom and her best friend
yeah she also gave to people what they
needed yes a hundred percent on a daily
basis um you've been going to grief
counseling um for those who
might be dealing with something like
this would you encourage them to go and
then also what have you
taken away from those sessions thank you
i would absolutely encourage anyone to
specifically see a grief counselor i
have a counselor that i've worked with
for many years but david and i have also
been talking with the grief counselor
to lose someone so suddenly
feels like they were snatched she like
she was snatched from my life
i don't know how to grieve that way i've
never had to before so i don't know what
it looks like and talking with someone
to find out that what i'm feeling what
i'm doing is normal and it is healthy
feeling what i feel um is normal and
healthy and some days i feel great i
feel like i'm april again
and other days i don't feel like myself
i'll think i'm okay and then i'll
realize that you know my hair has been
matted for two days and i need to just
take care of myself and i realize in
those moments i'm not okay
and that's okay
to not be okay in those moments it seems
like people that knew chesley
immediately thought about the great
memories yeah i have a ton of um you
know i've worked with her closely uh but
for you what are some memories that come
to mind that
help you deal oh
um
chesley and i spent a lot of time
together um the trip that we took to
turks and caicos last year was just
everything
um because we both just had a chance to
have fun many times when i would travel
with chesley it was for work um either
her work is miss usa or
on something that was related to what i
was doing
but
at turks and caicos we just hung out we
built sand castles we walked on the
beach we had breakfast we shopped um
that is one of my favorite memories yeah
of her i miss her laughs yes yes
light up the room miss her laugh just
her voice
her take on life the way that she
thought about things and i learned later
that she was a high functioning
depression
she was high functioning and a very
depressed person that we didn't know
is is there a way that you know because
we don't dwell on what we miss what we
could have done but is it something that
should be shared so that people could
reach out and help what is the right
thing to do in this situation because i
really struggled after and but i found
some comfort now
in in knowing that
that this was something that she had
talked about that she had talked with
you about
and i i was still struggling with in
april
what is the answer i don't know yeah
there um i will say this about chesley
um she's a very strong woman yes
and what she needed she sought and she
received
everyone isn't you know we're not
saviors
you may not be the person she needed
counsel about her depression from but
what you did provide her she needed
someone to talk to mentor her a
co-worker who smiled at her and gave her
a kind word laughed with her
she took what she needed
and i hope that people who knew her and
loved her will find comfort in knowing
that you did your part and you know you
gave her what she needed absolutely
absolutely and so
um sometimes in that
i find comfort
in knowing how strong of a woman she was
she was um
and that she sought what she needed when
she needed it in every area of her life
so there wasn't really something to see
if she didn't want you to see it you
weren't going to see it do you think she
put on the face yes she did yes
and there was you know there was
laughter she needed and sometimes when
someone finds out that you have
something like depression or severe
depression they treat you differently
treat you with kid gloves yes
and you don't want that good point what
what is most helpful to you during this
time what can what is the most and i
know it isn't one size fits all too i
think right make that clear it's
different things for different people
you know the wyoming judge said
something interesting the other day
after her own mother's death she said
it's so hard to be blessed and broken in
the same place
and and i wonder what would be most
helpful what is most and how can we
honor chesley
oh
chesley um you know she left a legacy
of kindness of advocacy
of
helping and supporting others
and it's in those acts that i see her
and so i've just been asking so many
people
advocate be kind those are ways that i
know chesley has impacted someone enough
that they are doing something to honor
her
that means everything yeah
wow thank you what means everything to
us for you to come today thank you it
really does really does thank you such
an important conversation thinking of
you thinking of her thinking of dave and
your family and other children your
other your other children too yes you're
still a mom still alive to many people
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
national alliance on mental illness
there's a helpline and the number is
1-800-950-6264
say it again
1-800-950-6264 in a crisis please text
n-a-m-i to 741-741
coming up we'll talk to a clinical
psychiatrist dr suvarma
we're continuing our conversation about
former miss usa and extra correspondent
chesley chris struggle with severe
depression she died by suicide in
january you just heard from her mother
april simpkins we are now joined by
board certified psychiatrist dr sue
varma and we should know that she never
treated christ um you know i want to tap
back into something that april said
she mentioned living with the sadness
what did you think of when you heard
those words
i think it takes great courage to live
in sadness and um i'm a believer that
grief and gratitude can co-exist i think
a lot of times people expect you either
to move on or to be living on the floor
in your sweatpants and grieving and i
think it looks very different for
different people and to be able to sit
with pain to me that is a one of the
greatest hallmarks of emotional maturity
to say this is where i am right now i'm
taken over by a wave of sadness and and
i'm going to live with it and i know
that this sadness will lift and i will
have brighter moments as well april also
said something very interesting about uh
people thinking they're saviors right so
many people cared about chesley and
would have wanted to do something but
chesley didn't reach out and she's sort
of freeing people april is by saying
look if she didn't reach out to she was
getting that support somewhere else i
think it's really important to
understand
it's about where you draw the line
between one's responsibility and what to
do what they could have done yes yes and
information that should be shared
you know is it something that should be
shared
you know ideally you know it's it's a
back and forth conversation to say
i'm really concerned about you i'm
worried about you you look amazing but i
imagine that you have told me sometimes
that this is hard for you that you're
struggling what's going on for you
inside i think it's so hard because we
want to be perceived as women who can
have it all so to speak but what's the
price you know this whole idea of high
functioning depression depression
typically isn't high functioning
depression has people on the floor in
the sweatpants not getting up not taking
care of themselves not grooming that's
the hallmark of it and so we're really
thrown off when we have somebody who is
perfectly put together and saying all
the right things and smiling at us and
you're like there's no way i would have
ever seen this so how do you check in
with somebody because but i like the
point you made though tony about savior
can you follow
i want to know what that means yeah when
april said you you can't be a savior yes
and look um i i have the utmost respect
for everybody here and i know that in
you know when you're a high achieving
person who's used to being a mentor and
being a support system in the community
and being a role model
you can look back and say what did i do
wrong and i think it's really important
what april said is you didn't do
anything wrong you were available this
person knew that you existed you knew
they knew that they could call you at
any time
but it's it's us that puts the blame
that i could have done something it's
that monday morning quarterback it's
part of grieving is to say could i have
should i have what could have been
different one split second one phone
call what could could something have
been different that's what that savior
complex and sometimes it's about guilt i
mean it's about guilt survivor guilt
also why am i here why are they not here
what's wrong with this picture how would
someone know
that
they either need to reach out to an
individual that might be struggling with
depression or how would
that individual who um is waking up and
they're not they're not understanding
the space that they're in and they're
not understanding that they could be
depressed how do they know that they
need to reach out to somebody yes so if
you find that you're having a
persistently low mood so in high
functioning depression what's different
is that it doesn't have the clear nice
discrete episodes that major depressive
disorder has where it's like you know
two weeks or four weeks in high
functioning depressive depression it's
also called persistent depressive
disorder where it's like a chronic low
level of what we call dysthymia it's a
low mood and you're still functioning
but if you're having this low mood that
doesn't go away and you say that i don't
have pleasure in the things that i once
used to enjoy or if me getting put
together and showing up in the world is
exhausting like if i had to go to lunch
with uh with gail and then i come home
and i sleep for five days because i was
like oh my god it was great but i'm
depressed like that took everything out
of me um and then checking in with
people to say i know you're doing so
much like you're on this show you're on
that show like are you taking time for
yourself no really like what does that
look like what does your self-care look
like
therapy mental health treatment for all
of us should be a part of our self-care
even from a preventative point of view
like that's so foreign to us that we
would go for an annual screening for a
mental health checkup but it really
should be a part of it and it is asking
people two simple questions have you
felt depressed lately are you feeling
down and are you getting pleasure out of
the things you once used to enjoy so
that should be something doctors should
be asking and we should be asking each
other are you are you still is this fun
for you or is this a lot my primary care
doctor did a last checkup and i was
impressed i was like oh this is new
awesome i like it yes yes two questions
can save a person's life
um being that i work with chester christ
for so long i have struggled with the
reality coming to grips with what
happened and what i should have or
should not have done um this show has
been um healing to me so i want to thank
cbs mornings and also april simpkins for
coming in sitting down because that that
was not easy and thank you dr sue varma
we appreciate you so much
again if you or someone you know is
seeking mental health resources you can
call the national alliance on mental
illness helpline at 1-800-950-6264
in a crisis text
n-a-m-i-741 rather 741 that is nami
741-741